- All right, everybody
let's get to scrolling through the pages
of social media to
share something awesome.
This is What I'm Liking.
(laughing)
No one saw that, but I did
and it was awesome Chris.
All hour we've celebrated
the joy of reading,
a woman in Colorado has found
a way to make it even sweeter.
She combined her love
of books with her love
for baking pies, a natural combo, I think.
Check these photos out.
Oh my God, looks good.
She bakes a pie for each book she reads,
- Whoa.
- I'm so hungry.
Her, wow.
Her baking skills have
even caught the attention
of Reese Witherspoon.
Say hi to Stephanie watching
on KOAA Southern Colorado,
Y'all.
All right so I dunno which I
like more the books or the pies
or just the combo is really nice.
So what book are you reading this month?
- Okay. Well, I am reading
the Lost for Words Bookshop
by Stephanie Butland.
- Oh
- It's been out for a
little while, but it is just
such a powerful love letter
to readers and the ability
of the written word to just
heal and bring us together.
And I just love it, but you know
if I made a book, I also made a pie.
Do you wanna see the pie?
- Girl? I love pie.
Stephanie. Let's see that pie.
I'm so sad you not here.
- All right, here is the pie.
- Oh my gosh that's amazing.
- Thank you.
- You are so talented. I
can't do anything like that.
Oh my gosh.
This is such a great way
One to like, first of all, pie and reading
this is a beautiful combination.
I applaud this and thank
you so much, Stephanie
for just, you know,
including us in this moment
and like making something
so cool on internet
and getting people to read,
also bringing pie to us.
- Yeah absolutely. Thanks for having me.
- Absolutely. I'm liking
your post right now.
It's incredible that you can do that.
Oh, that's not all, our
season long partner, Pilot Pen
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
likes to celebrate those
who create fearlessly
just like you, girl so
they will be using their
Frixion erasable pen to write you a check
for a thousand dollars, how's that sound?
That's a lot of books and a lot of pie.
- That's amazing, thank you.